Good
morning I'd like all these
hearing as accountability and
administrative review committee
and the veteran affairs
committee to order I it's
wonderful to have a number
advocates join us this morning
I'd like to thank you for your
manta ending veteran
homelessness here in Orange
County I am assembly woman
cutting Petrie-Norris I
represent the seventy fourth
assembly district after
assembly member as a member of
the Veterans Affairs committee
out as chair of the-
accountability and
administrative you committee.
Insuring that are taking care
of orange county's better and
is one of my top priorities and
address scene V. I.
homelessness in our population
in Orange County has been a
real area of focus as many you
know right now are at three
hundred and two. Most veterans
living on the streets Orange
County. One who has sacrificed
so much for our country who has
been so much for many of us.
Find themselves without roof
over their heads and that's why
it's part of the twenty
nineteen twenty twenty state
budget I was proud to be able
to secure two point nine
million dollars in funding. In
partnership with the Orange
County United Way. And veteran
homelessness here in Orange
County today will be getting an
update on. Program and a number
of other initiatives underway
here in Orange County. Our
conversation we are going to
dive into a couple of issues
first the scope and scale of
homelessness in Orange County
second best practices and
lessons learned in addressing
this issue- and another
communities and lastly the plan
to end veteran homelessness in
our county by twenty twenty. I
said thank you all again for
joining us today and thank you
terror when ask for holding
this hearing. With us today
would you like to make an
opening statement. Thank you
Lara thank you very much
assemblymember. Ours for biting
need to participate- this the
in trying hearing and good
morning everybody. As chair of
the- committee on veteran
affairs I'm familiar with the
state level. Birds are you a
veteran homelessness and with
major programs at the state
operates aimed at ending.
Veterans into shelter or
housing. And in fact I have a
bill that. Would ensure
continued funding of the
state's major veteran homeless
prevention initiative which I
hope to pass early next year.
Although I know my own
community well. And it's
experience informs my
understanding of the homeless I
says I can't pretend to know
what's going on in all fifty
eight other counties- the
opportunity doesn't come often
to dedicate so much time
interests to hearing in on the
gala ground perspective. Of
other communities and from
people who are working
directly. In these community to
shelter veterans indeed and so
I am very grateful to the chair
for conceding- this the idea of
this hearing. And her staff for
putting it together and
drawings of buried and
compelling. Selection of
speakers for the panels today.
Thank you. I will go ahead and
welcome our panelists hello
one. I welcome Shannon là
share hi Brian all of the air.
Is a Lima Lindy. Ray said the
rare. And Christopher. And car.
Thank you so much for joining
us. This morning I will go
ahead and start I Shannon. I
yeah. She lost her voice so
that would work for today's
hearing- but thank you so much
of bring us so I'm here provide
I'm an overview of the scope
and scale of an Orange County-
as assembly women Petrie-Norris
men can and in the two thousand
nineteen point in time how we
found and hundred and eleven
homeless veterans in our
community and that includes
sheltered and I'm sheltered I'm
the twenty nineteen point in
time count was really a key
moment for Orange County in
order to be able to understand
current homelessness but we did
with an actual account and
implemented new methodology.
That included the use of our
gas technologies everyone to
three so we can locate where
veterans aren't I'm and return
to those three pots and out
reach to them we also
incorporated half sheet in
which we collect that thirteen
person identifying data points
for the better and that would
help us understand and follow
up with them future outreach
efforts. That their name the
veteran status branch of
service character of this
charge and any other additional
like contact details that they
were willing to share. We were
really excited that. Of those.
Two hundred and twelve out
reach during the sheltered
count- approximately half of
them provided that information
for us. That was often
opportunity to reconcile our
veteran registry. And the
veteran registry list is the by
name list of all the veterans
in Orange County I and eight is
populated by all the street
outreach workers nonprofit
fifties- that conduct our
region our community and that
encounter veterans and that way
we are able to follow up with
them and see their progress
towards helping make sure that
we connect those veteran to a
case manager- healthy
navigation services the- able
to transition out of homes
that. An active support.
Resource. I'm going back live
it to the point in time cap and
as you mentioned it was three.
In the lab and veterans. This
represents roughly 3% of the
homeless population in all of
Orange County I'm which the
nineteen point in time cannot.
Found. Six thousand eight
hundred sixty individuals
experiencing homelessness in
Orange County. I am and we have
the opportunity to also do a
deeper dive on that. The
populations and demographics of
the veterans- so we found that.
Of the veterans bring think
almost of the majority of them-
near over a quarter of them our
seniors their sixty two years
of age and older after we have
an aging population of that.
Marking unity. At the majority
of the homeless veterans are
male approximately 90% of the
veterans I'm county during when
in time county. I'm in nearly
half of them are experiencing
chronic homelessness meaning
that they have been. On the
streets for a year longer and
have a disabling condition. I'm
that also makes them eligible
for the high fashion. Which is
showing that we have the
adequate resources to help.
Veteran homelessness- and then
others the populations are
characters is of our veterans
and we noticed that. Nearly one
in five veterans reported a
mental health issue. And one
third of our press reported a
physical disability. And one
quarter. Veterans reported
having substance use issues.
After having this detail
information of the populations
than other demographics allows
an opportunity to tailor
services to the veterans and
stand and the connections that
we need to make to with them to
other support services. To
ensure that they- are able to
receive the care that they need.
Over time I'm Orange County has
had focus in addressing veteran
homelessness and like other
communities in the nation I
have been successful in
decreasing veteran home last
I'm so proud of two thousand
nineteen to do that then I mean
sorry from two thousand fifteen
to two thousand nineteen there
was. A 34% decrease in veteran
homelessness. And sent the
point in time county now which
is approximately. Like ten
months I have we have seen a
15% decrease in veteran
homelessness I'm just by really
targeting are offered and- care
for the veterans. The going
forward we will continue- to
manage the veteran registry the
veteran registry the mention of
the by name of all right to
experiencing homelessness an
Orange County- and these folks
are. At the mention are entered
by a street outreach teams and
community organizations after
the number of the veteran
registry will fluctuate over
time as we are reach to more
friends and as veterans get
house- but we have a downward
trend which means that. Meeting
our efforts I'm is definitely
helping. I and this veteran
registry is maintained weekly
so we have weekly meetings to
be able to contact the follow
up and make sure that we don't.
Have any veterans fall through
the cracks. Or that were able
to our reach to them properly.
I'm out of the yesterday there
were two hundred and sixty
veteran health hold on the
veteran registry. Thank you for
the work that you're doing
thanks for being here- are
there any questions for the
panelists or- need to our next.
The forty five I'd like to
introduce a member Sharon quirk
Silva. By next year would you
like to make a- comment before
we move on. Good morning I want
to thank us the chair of this
committee or both chair should
say of the Veterans Committee
and accountability. Ability
committee for hosting this here
in Orange County- as- I look
out there I see some familiar
faces that have been working on
veterans issues for quite a
long time and on housing issues
the two issues. Are coincide
and have been part of the work
that I've been doing I. Always
is an exile yeah opportunity to
learn more myself about these
two issues but also went on I
have Gaines information to
share it's all just take one up
point to privilege here I was
had the opportunity yesterday
to- go to the campus of cal
poly. Which is out of my
district but ana was invited
for tour there and was able to
go to the veteran center there
resource center- which is ca.
Well rounded place very active.
And spoke to a few of the
veterans firsthand and of the
things again that I've heard
cents my days as being chair of
Veterans Committee. It is where
are we not making the
connection for veterans once
they leave- we've talked about
the taps program their program
when they leave and it was a
very stained remarks that I've
heard really for the last
almost six years that. When
they are ready to leave and
they're going to their
orientation program that they
just want to get home. SO some
of the last things they're
thinking about is all the
paperwork and how to make the
connections. It isn't sometimes
until. A handful of months
later. At the connections have
been lost so even through that
very short dialogue one of the
things that we try to get back
to is how can we- if you want
to say. Figure out a way to get
that connection so that when
they are ready for it because
you can't make them- just if
you want to say go directly to
a benefits officer if they're
not ready for that but- of the
same kind of advice was given
the you know reconnecting so
forth but one is to use some of
the social media and-
information and our phone.
Which is perhaps get veterans
that have been there already
and then maybe it six months
after they returned home more a
year and all of a sudden now
they're ready but they're not
sure how to navigate and for
them to actually do a little
testimony so that that could be
pushed out there too veterans
so that they can actually see
firsthand. That maybe within
the first two months four
months six months are not ready
for that information. But a
year later and so they can get
first hand testimony which is.
A live video something like
that that's pushed out to them
somehow- through an email or a
text message so they can see
that okay now I'm ready this is
what I need to do. Because
sometimes we talk about big
programs that cost a lot of
money. But this could be a very
simple testimonies from
somebody who's working with the
navigation officer or with the
county veteran officer so that
they can say I was finally
ready these are the steps I
took but its first hand. So
that's just from yesterday that
Kalpoe E. but anyhow I look
forward thank you. Thank you
are will now hear from a couple
of local veterans who are
thanks for being here with that
Hey you're saying your purse
seven terms of transition
particularly in terms of. Our
housing challenges that you
face. Our our with a broken
often. A good morning members
of the committee- good morning
everyone thank you for having
me here to get- my name's Brian
all. Of those in the United
States Marine Corps for about
four and a half years I was
eighteen twelve tanker. Twice
once the Middle East these-
Asia. And I got out in two
thousand seventeen. When I got
out I had thought that I
planned everything out I had a
job lined up. I had a seven
thousand dollar savings- I just
I had everything lined up and
one of the reasons why. I think
that I you know went through
these challenges was because of
circumstances that I couldn't
quite control- they were out of
my hands. One of the biggest
reasons for me was is something
that they don't tell you about
the GI is that it's not
considered stable income so
what I mean by that say. You
can't use it as proof of income
you can't use that as- safer
like pay stubs to qualify for
an apartment for a car or
anything- yet when and you try
to apply for financial aid from
school or try to apply for
something like how fresh they
say that you make too much
money. So it kind of just cut
at the knees. I got out with a
one year old daughter I had a
family- a lot of veterans to
come out you know by themselves
but then there's also veterans
that you'll come out with the
family. I have people that I a-
and responsible for so- I was
lucky enough to find an
apartment a four hundred square
foot studio. For fourteen
fifty. An Orange County in
Tustin. It was. A time of my
life that I'd- made me a better
person- made me stronger but
it's a time period that don't
like to go back to because it
was very hard. Partly due to
some of the restrictions of the
GI bill so. One of the rules
that they don't explain to you
is how the GI works for
instance I got out my E. A. S.
for end of active service will
temas sixteen two thousand
seventeen. I got out two months
ahead of time because I had a
job I had you know a family out
of an apartment I to get
situated so I can have
everything lined up perfectly
and the rules stipulate with
the GI bill is a you have to be
out completely for an entire
month. And yet you have to be.
For an entire month. So I
didn't actually get any type of
income until December and I got
out in August fourth- at seven
thousand dollars. In Orange
County does not last long
especially when you're you
know. You're monthly rent is
fourteen fifty that shows. You
you don't just come out. Three
you still have. To store up
responsibilities. And so
ultimately I was living
paycheck to paycheck. I had a
job lined up as you know you
don't just get paid right away.
I you know. It was a very tough
situation for me- and also had
a kid out of one year old
daughter it was just something
that. Eight it got really scary
for me I thought for one minute
thousand be living in my car.
You know my family you know
something that. You know
contemplating you think how did
I get in the situation Iraq
planned everything out so
perfectly. How did that get in
the situation your
circumstances that I just
couldn't control I just had to.
Make do with what I had you
know. Part of the biggest
reason why I think I've made it
so far as obviously because my
daughter the love my dog but-
the family that I found Irvine
valley college- namely Nancy
Montgomery who's been a-
guarding angel from and she-
has. You know a lot of
resources for me. That allowed
me to you know survive for the
past- you know markets. But
yeah I just- you know part of
these parties problems are you
know things that they don't
quite explain and there's a lot
of yellow tape around these
things and- how. How are you
supposed to you know make do
with the cost of living you
know this is. My client so.
Part of what I think would help
out is- finding a place where
you know veterans coming out of
the service have somewhere to
go somewhere where they can be
for like temporary housing
somewhere they they can use for
time short period where they
can at least get on their knees
you know not a okay back on
their feet I should say. Yeah I
think looking back that would
have helped a lot- I think.
About. The suicide the rates of
suicide for veterans I don't
want to sit here and say that
the plate suicide but suicide
was a definitely options but
you know there's certain things
you can't control you don't you
know what are you supposed to
do. And I've had a lot of
friends a commit suicide at.
Outside of the service you know
and it's just. Can I consider
myself one of the lucky ones
because I had a good support
system around me a friend you
know. Being from- far away from
my family Georgetown Kentucky
coming to Orange County all by
myself. It was it was pretty
hard but I'm here and I hope
that my testimony can help
bring light to the situation.
Thank you. Christopher Abbott
as Christopher can we hear your
perspective as well absolutely.
Absolutely thank you for mere
gratitude of my take your Brian
thank you for sharing a
compelling story as your
personal experiences my take is
really a little bit about my
personal experience and the
data. And at. So average
household income this is a at a
master's degree level to run AT
que roughly I'm estimated and
their their positions where
like for example I have three
kids I have a family of three
we were in housing and there
was a time when I was going to
school full time and working
80% eighty like 80% of my time
was invested in my occupation
which is a banking entry level
bachelor's degree position and
I was barely able to pay and
for like at a one bedroom
apartment. As a comparison. I
just imagine of the you know
from personal experience. How
much the Martine that gap has
has shifted income is very
consistent however the markets
for. Has changed dramatically
right that there's a huge gap
meaning I was very fortunate. I
have to be very grateful
because my wife's a veteran as
well I was the United States
Marine Corps she was as well so
I did have a little bit more
foundation I'm of I have a
family when I transition out of
service. However I felt the
blow of the housing market the
disparity between the income
verses- you know the
credibility factor is that and
what it takes to survive in
Orange County. So I do at the
perspective like I said I have
I have a ball for my wife was
on the GI bill as well I know
it's just extremely. Hard and
might might take away is. The
pain points I want to say you
know. For contesting for
veterans and a providing
services a call to action would
be to. Present some kind of
resource where but veterans
that our tradition
transitioning are getting
suitable. Housing situations
situation maybe a partnership
amongst different communities
to housing these veterans going
to this transition process
because the fact is it is
extremely hard out there to
have a family for example and
to pay your rants. On such a
low standard of income when
housing market just keeps
increasing in income this
relatively stays the same I
apologize a little bit from my
scattered- scattered speech are
the. Burns was there and it was
very hard for my family. And
movie for I think there is you
better solutions provide for
veterans such as Brian
transitioning out of service
trying to ascend himself in
society get to a much higher
degree level and cutting
through the noise of. Pain for
housing taking care of a family
going to school battling all
the depression and all the
personal experiences and all
the battles that they have you
know internally and also
keeping like moving that ball
that Neil for in their life so
that's thank you for your time
thank you for. Hearing me out
and that's my speech. Thank you.
That race the Carrera. Good
morning to all for someone to
say are take a second at the
two thank you for your time for
allow me to be in front of you
guys a little trouble myself my
name's residents- I served in
the United States Navy I was
eighty which is a- mechanic-
I'm attending IBC right now
looking for to transfer to
pursue a degree in mechanical
engineering- I'm I'm currently
using my GI benefits and
currently also do work city at
school at school in about
center- I was born and raised
in Savannah. And that is
actually were aye when move
back right now to help my mom
into their brothers to aye
financially. Support them as
much as I can right now on my
way back home. After returning
back from the service- today- I
just want to bring up three of
the biggest issues that have
been calendar. Since you
leaving and it's affordability.
Accessibility and
discrimination. Affordability
there's no rent control in
Orange County. And with that
being said- as you've been
hearing but these my to Bob.
Veterans the little- are they
they've experienced a an
increase or rent. So there's
really no control and the
landlords have pretty much most
of the power. And the deciding
how much rent you know they
could raise up. And I
understand that if it's more
than 10% they do have to do a
sixty day notice but there's
really no control over how much
money they could raise it up-
recently I experience of
flooding in August nineteen.
And with that you know I've
been. Momentarily this place
where we're kind of just look
in the little room us all four
together. And with that being
said he the landlord already
kinda hit to us that he will
raise or by more than twenty
percent- because of the
renovations and he's doing-
concert with me with that is
that. That is a- a lot of like
a maintenance in the area where
I live in the apartment complex
and I live in the- live close
to send out a high school so
it's nine two seven zero one.
It's going to be one of the
lower income on a as an Orange
County. And of some of the
concerns that I have is that
on. He actually has an
apartment upstairs that he
reserves like Airbnb. I don't
know that is legal I have done
a couple of you research and I
have yet to follow and like
find the code that says that
that is okay to do- that also
brings me down to the says
ability- second concern that I
have been with that is that- I.
Have been seen a an increase.
And auto but short term rentals
in the area. And I understand
that a certain cities it are
clear it is very clear fight in
the states that it is legal.
But in Santa Ana itself but I
haven't done the will and
research to. To find it- so
with that we live next I live
next to touching like the
fences and a high school- with
that with the Airbnb I don't
know. Who is going in and out.
It could be a pet a file a
sexual you know harasser.
There's really no control
through those. Those apps-
who's going in and out of. That
apartment so that is my
concern. With that and also
others a lot of renovations but
I don't see inspectors out
there. I don't know their
building without permit and I
and I understand that since
it's a lower income area a lot
of people are free to speak up
and actually bring up certain
situations like that. And that
is why. You know a lot- you
know people in my area they get
they speak up and they just as
were in a month to month lease.
That's very common also an
Orange County- we just. We get
elected. So I am afraid I am
afraid that if I actually say
something go to the city. You
know. I'm gonna get evicted and
where am I gonna go with my
family my mom in the cooler
weather. Another another point
with the sensibility is the VA
loan. I actually attempted to
purchase a small condo under
three hundred thousand because
I know that's something that I
could possibly afford. And the-
the issue with that was that
the VA loan dozen- they don't
count your GI income. They
don't count it as income. Seoul
this is not stable so that that
idea was off the- my list. The
other thing that I attempted to
do especially with the
frustration with the flooding.
Was you know research research
for a low income housing. They
say I make too much money
because they count the GI bill
as income. So for federal
programs they count. GI bill as
income but- for a VA loan I can
buy a home because they don't
count as income so I'm kind of
stuck in the middle. I decided
to what to do. The last thing
that I want to talk about this
discrimination. I've actually
experience I know that a
there's a certain image that
some people have veterans or
disabled veterans. And what
that you know over up personal
experience that I've experience
was- my landlord- I asked if he
could. Keep it down in the
construction after a certain
amount of time- due to- you
know so you know certain mental
you know. Issues that I
experience and I cannot
tolerate like really loud
noise. Especially late at
night. And he actually couple
questions. And I quote. But I
didn't think you. Want to
combat. So being a woman being
in the navy. You know people
have their own pictures or even
just as a veteran to have their
pictures. Of what issues they
actually have because I might
seem normal you know we might
seem okay you know physically
right up front of you. But the
you know. A lot of people don't
know what goes on in our head
when we're alone. And I just.
In conclusion I just you know I
just want you guys to my
experiences with you know with
housing as a veteran of the
three issues that I encounter
are portability USCIS ability
in discrimination I might not
be homeless now what of these
issues remain me and- veterans
responding up in the streets.
Thank you for your time. Well
thank you and to all three of
you thank you for your service
and thank you for being here.
With us today to share your
important perspective as we
have this conversation. It's
absolute heartbreaking I need
to hear. Your story feeling
like you've been discriminated
against for your service when
you come out of the military.
We need to ensure that at. We
don't. We don't just talk about
honoring our veterans on
veterans day at that we honor
you in our actions and our
deeds and as the work that we
do as policy makers and- that
is why we are here. Today. Any
questions or comments and seven
number. Thank you it to the
three of you for sure answers I
had one quick question Brian is
the best to. Answer that. We
are always cause concern
transitions and how do we make
sure that. When you leave the
service that you receive all
the information you need to
know all the back. Your title
to did you visit a CVS so or
did you get your information on
your- college. Or did did you
participate in the cal cap
program any of those resource-
so in the last year that was in
the marine corps I tended to
summon are called to TRS
seminar which all marines are
supposed to take- it's-
transition readiness. Me I
don't remember the last the
last name of it- but yes I
attended it was a week long and
what it is that you go through-
possible job so you can get-
that according to your- job in
the marine corps- the other.
Part it was your benefits
package- what you qualify for
what you can qualify for
incoming now- and- you're
supposed to get. Eight months
before you get out of the
marine corps and then your push
back in two years the person
you know go pick up drive will
stand guard whatever. It is
it's kind of just ridiculous
it's kind of a check in the box
if- I have learned more about-
the things that qualify from
veterans from word of mouth.
That have from these TRS
programs I've heard the same
thing from you know other
service members such as and not
you know being in the army and
the navy of all said the same
thing I've- learned more. About
some of these- programs through
friends people who- you know
who are far the VSO or
something like that have told
me about it so. Thank you.
Again thank you for your
testimony but- another way to
say testimony is you stories
and there they are child and
real and- everything that you
mentioned about how seen an
Orange County is absolutely
true and I think made harder.
By as your story that you get-
repeat to come back- from the
appointment and now have to
access everything from banking
two two jobs all at the same
time so my take away on this is
going to be. To work with my
partners up here too I don't
believe that we do have
transitional housing at all and
even the short term. Could be a
possible a pilot program here
in Orange County. That you know
like you said even if it's a
three month and then another
type of housing after that but
I think that three months on
ticket to. If you haven't
already worked with the CVS so
or if you still have questions
but even to clarify what led
you said about your benefits
what you can use them for
because it does look like it's
a double edged sword where on
the one hand it helps you. Two
but on the other hand- they
don't take it into account as
far as a bank loan so those are
certainly things that. You know
some of it federal government
but some of it at the state. We
certainly can look into and
that's exactly why these
hearings are so important is
for us to gain information but
as I opened with where I'm Y.
remarks is. Even us and I know
we have it because it's being
recorded but even a snapshot of
your testimony I think could be
very valuable- to the young
military personnel that are
exiting because your saying
what's happened to you from
experience. And some of those
that type of testimony I think
is very valuable because as I
noted when you're exiting
you're thinking of everything
about. You know how you're
going to set up a home for your
young daughter or where you're
going to locate to sell all the
intricacies. An orientation to
you're not probably paying
attention to but if there's a
first hand testimony from
another officer like you said a
word of mouth that may have
much more impact. For you for
those exiting than a binder
full of- information and both
combined I think could be very
valuable. Thank you again.
Thank you so much for joining
us I will go ahead and
transition. Thank you. Right I
would. But now lives to call up
our second panel the first we
have a steep pack who is the
president of US backs. And then
we have to keep Portland who's
the deputy secretary of
veteran's services for Calvet.
And Nancy Montgomery who is the
assistant dean health wellness
and better service is Irvine
valley college. And finally
hiding Marshall managing
director. Riverside county.
Riverside county something I'm
sure. Allen thank you all for
joining us today
. And why don't
we go ahead and start with
Mister. Much. A good morning of
my name is Steven pack on the.
I should president and CEO of
your steps I'm also a Vietnam
veteran. And I've been working
with homeless veterans
assistance in nineteen ninety
one. I bit down Orange County
several times in the past years
that you have as- Orange County
of struggle as many counties
have without their homeless
veteran issue. I within the US
has been serving up veterans
since nineteen ninety three- we
started in Los Angeles that are
in the website. And now have
expanded to eleven different
communities across country the
house. About fifty five hundred
dead better ends and
everything. They have a variety
of programs response to the
homeless crisis that we all
face. I'm also the president of
the California search veterans
service agencies seven agencies.
And are California- providing
housing and services from
Eureka to San Diego. Level two
of benefit to veterans. Right
now are Orange County like of
most county are- offering from
a shortage of affordable
housing you're always more or
of veterans and other homeless
people becoming homeless and-
then there's nothing available
so it is obvious to us that
housing own is not the answer
when you need a variety of
solutions- with your three
hundred or so almost veterans-
you can multiply that by two
and a half so. And comes out to
about a thousand veterans are
experiencing homeless
homelessness- every year- so we
have to attack. This problem
from a variety of different
angles. US vets has a
transitional housing program
both both transitional and
bridge programs. Of we have
almost prevention programs- and
a permanent support of housing
programs- and between the three
of those we hope that we will
get ahead of this problem. Of
the trend transitional housing
programs. Are largely funded by
the a grant and per diem
program that the program has
been flat line. Across the
country but the transitional
housing gives us the funding to
hire more staff so we can
provide more intensive services
those are rehabilitation
programs. For a while I think
transition hasn't got a bad
name it was you know ninety
days route ten people were
getting into permanent housing
but- of the way a- we have
redesigned as he a as
redesigned program is that.
Instead of the behavior health
assessments we are doing
housing tests how do we get
them- into housing. Of veterans
have a variety of issues.
Before they become homeless you
could be of- lack of a job the
could subsidies could be mental
illness. Of opportunity lack of
employment of a whole variety
of things that we have to deal
with those issues- really
before stabilizer the veterans
that's why. We feel- and we
also advocate that transitional
housing programs are are a key
part of this continuing. To get
veterans from the street into a
program house. But we also need
to look up stream. To homes
prevention. Of because of
veterans are becoming homeless
every day Los Angeles three or
four day are becoming homeless
are dropping and homelessness
so we obviously have to get
ahead of that and provide the
services that we provide a
rocket mental health and
employment services. Knowing
that those are two of the key
factors- that are resulting in
a homelessness- US vets
provides health counseling at a
through or outside the wire
program at seven our community
colleges in order county- and
another seven in- Los Angeles
county. And there we are
providing mental health
counseling to veterans who have
just come back from department
of our community colleges their
first step. But there's no way
that they really don't know
what happens beyond that in a
lot of them are are suffering
from come back home and we want
to make sure that they deal
with that early on- we're
providing case management. To
help them navigate- the. There
post service career. Knowing
that- some of them are dropped
into a community and really
don't know what's what steps to
take next in order to. Move
forward and we're providing
counseling to the families.
Families are dealing with- some
with commentator ends who have.
Are greatly disturbed by their
I'm in combat and we want to
help the family address that.
There's a very high suicide
rate among both men but a
particularly. Women the veteran
of suicide rate is six to
twelve times higher than their
sickly under parts of so it is
really important that we
provide discounts going on in a
Broadway are are outside the
program was has been privately
funded for the five years that
we run it just past year Orange
County department mental health
is picked up that funding I
think it is critical that all
counties look at their
prevention early intervention
so that they can provide this
counseling to both male and a
female veterans. Along with the
shortage of mental health
services there's a shortage of
employment dollars always- as
though there's the VP program
our problem the state is moved
around from- agency to agency
there ever enough to go around
and so it's a very stable
program- and getting a job. Is
one of the key. Issues that we
can handle to make sure that
veterans dog Fala to
homelessness. And fine is a
primitive supporting half
supporter housing- in
California now there is a lot
of money available for. A
homeless to for the
construction of homeless
veterans housing- and are we
really have to take advantage
of that- locating these are
permits for the projects in the
county of provides a number of
nodes of- intensive services.
And really stabilizes the
entire homeless veteran that
situation by locating the so-
because this money at them
we're I think we're and- round
five. Around five we're gonna
try to get it we're gonna try
to get some more fun after that
but- we have a couple more
rounds before this this run
this my expires we have all
have to be aggressive to go out
and get this money and build a
housing that's going to
stabilize. The homeless
veterans in our community- I
mention Kassar our state-
advocacy agency- we have been
advocating for a number of
years now our initially- about
appointment we are one of the
key advocacy groups behind. The
H. H. P. program and we are now
moving into battle health
knowing that another critical
issue. We did a state of the
veteran community report. Of
this past year this year's our
second. Report. To get a clear
sense of. It which counties are
providing veterans services and
which are not. Most are not
most are not coordinating count
of veterans services with
county services and I think
that's a critical. Of people
here that we want to fix. Aside
from the issues that I've
already mentioned- there's been
a notable absence of
partnerships between parents
specific agencies and counties.
There's a lot generally Oct of
access to better treatment
courts. And we are now focusing
on aging veterans aging
veterans are becoming a larger
part of the homeless population
I think we have to look ahead
to or what services are we need
our take care of that
population so that. They don't
they don't remain on the
street- so I would encourage
everyone to look at our website
the California veterans dot org
that- stated the veteran-
report is on there. As I
mentioned that to nearly every
day of. Our everyday several
veterans are falling into
homeless is- nearly every day
veterans are dying street I
think it's critical that we
address this problem in an
aggressive way- both are. All
the better and- this specific
parts of funding county funding
state funding we all have to
advocate together to. Bring the
services difference to prevent
them from remaining in
homelessness thank you. Thank
you for the opportunity here
today- let this one up I want
to thank the veterans who were.
By their- their testing isn't.
The only woman cursed said
their their store. See you can
conversation of how it doesn't
immediately leading though many
other things Steve just
mentioned which is you know
employment education physical
mental health- just it there's
a there's a holistic process
here that. Way we at the
department of Veterans Affairs
are very aware of and- worked
very closely with our nonprofit
providers in our county system
our community college system
and various others and if
there's any encouragement here
today it seems that some of
that process did work- some of
the folks family and see they
found Steve shop. And that
makes a big difference that
that means they're tied into us
that means they're tied and the
rest of their community
resources so. That is
encouraging on obviously a lot
of this is. You know has it has
historically been a challenge
with the department of defense.
On some of the transition
process people wonder why why
why is it so difficult for
service members and- everyone
looks at the type of services
their experiences within the
service but it's just it's
really fundamental. It's your
leaving an organization at your
part of your basically moving
perhaps in in relocating to a
new area. Or coming back to an
area where you've been.
Detached from for some period
of time- with unemployment. Or
within like made like the-
German said today that with
employment in place but once
again that's new appointments
you don't know if that's always
going to work out it's just a
very. Unstable transitional
period of time. And you know.
It's no surprise that the
department fences is
underperforming terms of
getting their- their service
members ready for that
transition when they- when they
get out. So here in state we've
obviously taken that our
responsibility for that very
seriously with the support of
the legislature and the
governor- we've been able to
put some great programs in
place and one of which-
assembly member when you
mentioned was cal top program.
A program we're very proud of
and now we're on all military
installations within the state
and providing. On transitional
services to those members who
desire that- it's not mandatory
we can't make them go- we ask
all of those that have any
intentions on standing
California please take part
because a lot of a- lot of
information for them and they
level that is very. Locally
specific- connect them with
their local CVS so connects
them with my out reached out.
There and all the other
community resources available.
Our representatives from the
community college system common
talk about the- local
educational opportunities- I
have staff come and educate
them on. Their educational
benefits department consumers
affairs comes in and provide
some information on how to
avoid predatory practices.
Veterans benefits- but this is
all it's all one big thing- as
Steve mentioned we recently
Steve does a wonderful job
with. With Nancy and work with
outside the wire program to get
that on community colleges here
Orange County which is a model
that we took in with our prop
sixty three fund- recently
worked with with Steve's
organization and LA to get that
same program on to the- the
twenty three community college
systems. US campuses within the
LA area. So. Can't stress
enough the prop sixty three
money that each county. Housing
is available- and better it's
not veterans specific but
better answer one of the
populations and not. That fall
under the usage of that funding
so- it's very important for
every county tap into that in.
And work with the base
providers to make the most of
that money within their county
which is obviously supporting
many of these housing programs-
California. We do have the
veterans housing homes
prevention program. We we've
we've kind of re look at the
way we look at housing within
our department and- want to
provide a continuum of care.
We've just we've- we've always
had a farm and home loan
program is- offers purchasing
opportunities for folks-
wonderful program incredibly
successful for decades and
decades. However the only folks
that were ready for that. Take
that step towards their
California Dreamin own their
own home could apply on an
obviously as we know a better
answer. Over represented in the
homes population so clearly we
have some work to do on that
end- and then we always had our
eight homes as well. So we had
some housing options but
obviously a lot of gaps so with
the re purposing of some of the
bond money we had six hundred
million at the time. We were
able to really bridge a lot of
those gaps anywhere from a
merchant housing through
transitional to permit
supportive to affordable on
then ideally have the option
for ownership there are farming
home all program and then
obviously later on in life on
being able to reside in one of
our veterans home to try to
create that continuum of
housing for. The provided by
the department. Many credibly
successful thus far- sixty two
projects have been awarded the
first four rounds about three
hundred and nine million of
that six hundred million have
gone out- interestingly enough
the first project the came
online was right here in Orange
County was potter's leading. It
was a program that was- created
a put on very rapidly because
they you- shipping containers
to reform and to build the
units- so very very good.
Program it's been often running
for a couple years now. So that
that's moving along well as I
said much of that is it's a
long. Some of it's got 25% of
those units are affordable at
the twenty four units. Online
to the sixty two programs are
without 25% being affordable-
another 25% Being permits
supportive- I don't remember
the exact numbers on some of
the others but those are two of
the big the big areas only one
thing to note on Steve mentions
a bit too is only 15% of those
units as far have been for.
Families on. When you look at
better ends in the units
available particularly females
with children- our numbers are.
It's hard to grasp of this but
our number Chau there's less
than five hundred units
statewide available at the
moment or- for women with
children men with children for
that matter. There's a lot lot
of challenges around serving a
population- là security issues
that I think were mentioned
here today- in a for a variety
other issues around some of
the- some the additional
barriers that folks might have.
On the take a little more
cultural competency in order to
serve that population and make
it a little tougher which I
think maybe. Why they are under
represented in what's of
available to them. But moving
forward that certainly a target
of ours the- funds had been
distributed I think early on
LA- as as kind of expected to
the lion's share of a lot of
the money- but it is balanced
out. Quite nicely- Orange
County. We I don't think
there's two projects going on
an Orange County right now
neither have. The H. H. P.
funding available to them the
Santa Ana veterans village
program in the Placentia
veterans- village. And mercy
housing jamboree housing to
doing those- one one part of
our program we really love it
and I know the Santa Ana
veterans village I'm not sure I
want to speak for. The forty
but be here to pull century.
But one thing about the PhD
program is really unique. But I
think it's can change the way
the state is looking at housing
overall. Is that it require
this element of words or with-
on. Working with groups like
caps so which caps. So was. Was
at the front of five.
Redirecting that six hundred
million towards this purpose-
they advocated very hard
initially to have that would
support services would be
required as part of the
agreement for the development.
Developer gets the grant until
they have a supportive
services- package approved by
my shop- which were very
excited about because clearly
as we mentioned that as I
started off today there's a
there's a variety of other
issues that go along with. With
being almost any pre addressed
to. Citizens so once again
thanks for the opportunity to
be here today and I'm
interested to hear what
everyone else has to say and
we're certainly here to assist
anyway we can thank you. Thank
you Mister Boyle ms Montgomery.
Thank. Okay hi I just want to
interrupt just really briefly
you've come up in the lobby I
can the last two years and that
the program you have it really
still as well for the state and
if we could get something that
every community college we
would really be serving our
veterans idents thank you so
much and you've been wonderful
to aye you were first assembly
member we came to her that
finding it you open your door
and your arms and greed
everything from there so I have
to thank you for that too along
with John bang who was with you
on that part too so. I
appreciate everything you've
done I do you explain that
program just what that is
exactly so yeah sure so we have
at Irvine valley college we
have the veteran resource
center there and we consider it
kind of a best practice
resource center because we're
an overall complete stop so
every type of service that we
have in this state or any
institution we offer right
there we have certified
Fishel's be able perhaps in
there we have disability
certification we have and
everything's on site it's not
like there we have to resource
them out we have- through U. S.
about bats outside where we
have four days a week of mental
health- provisions for. Our
veterans specific so they're
actually train from the be a
when they come in and work with
our veterans so they're used to
working with combat- military
sexual assault the main issue
suicide ideation those type of
things- we offer all types of
emergency finds we aye right
consistent grant so that we can
provide a lot more services we
anything. To do with them we
provide. Money. One stop and
that's what kind of makes this
a little bit different than
most of the other veterans
throughout the state which is
nice- my background is.
Military it's nursing so I look
at it more of a holistic view
that kind of brings a little
bit more medical and mental
health to it. Which I think
promotes that wellness part of
it too so I think that helps-
and I'm a date a nerd too so
just real briefly I want to
give you some of the data. In
Orange County we have over
twelve thousand veterans that
attend the nine community
colleges. Throughout the state
we have over ninety thousand
that attend the hundred and
fourteen community college. A
recently we have an innovation
grant that we went out and did
a study. And we look at what's
going on in these hundred
fourteen community colleges out
of that we were able to access
a hundred and six because- the
other eight did not really have
services on their campus for
veterans. When we went out
there we hired our P. group to
come out big evaluation for
they did focus groups they did.
A small groups of veterans they
talked with we did tons of
surveys we did over fifteen
hundred surveys with veterans
so we got a pretty good.
Glimpse of what we're looking
at. We do specifically talk
about housing because there's
so many application- issue we
had a look at. But in the
snapshot. They did. Talk about
living arrangements living
arrangements with other. 79% of
our veterans live with others-
alone with nineteen percent.
And then homeless was 3% and
that's what we got out of only
those fifteen hundred. There
are those still sleeping in
their cars commuting back and
forth and going from there that
we don't usually find out
about. Until somebody speaks up
and says that which then we
can. Enact our services and go
from there. I think that we
have a lot of. Resources
recently through this
innovation grant we held. A
conference at Irvine valley
college and we had a- two
hundred attendees from
community colleges. Some for
four years what we did was put
together had my step put
together a binder. And I think
this binder something that
we've got to get out a lot more
because people need the
resources they need the
templates they need the
information. I used Calvet to
put together some information.
L. A. homeless. Indeed our
groups that provide housing
there. So throughout here we
have all this hopefully we keep
adding to this. We have intake
forms with certified official
information counselors. But
inside the- other part is
information about how to access
food. There Calvet brash how to
get on food pantries. Because a
lot of people don't look at
those things they don't know
how to get to a- it. Also
through a complete list of
housing. At any other Calvet
office in LA put this together
and then I have- been dials put
it together for us in the
Orange County office of these
are. Available housing for
veterans that they can apply to
and hopefully get into. Some
are a little bit difficult
because they do require vast
vouchers the bash doctor system
I think needs a little over
hall here- I think we need. A
lot more easier access to those
vouchers but also we need a lot
more outside apartment owners
willing to accept those
vouchers and- follow up with
that- it. This goes over a lot
of great resources. I talked
about what we need their- part
of the emergency. Grants that
we hand out our to put down
their first month payment. It's
to pay for utilities that they
can't pay for that they can
afford we offer on any type of
clothing that type of things
and it comes out of all these
grants that we actually bright.
Eyed and provide for them. You
would be surprised at you were
Christopher talk he has three
children and his wife. His
bills every month there were
six thousand dollars him as
wife together bring in six
thousand dollars he was working
in the evenings. And on. To
trying to. Get some more funds
their history three little
babies which baby sitting alone
in orange. If you've ever
looked up that cost it ranges
anywhere from twelve hundred to
eighteen hundred dollars. And
that's only for one child. So
we put all of these type of-
beer years that they're trying
to. Navigate through any. Makes
it very difficult to school
could be. Done. I'm a calling
Danny that's on his real name
but it we're gonna calling the
need for today. He's come on
and off to our- college he
takes music classes he takes
different classes he's in his
early sixties he's- probably
the most sweetest manual ever
meet he was a boxer in the
army. So we actually went to
the Olympic Olympics and box.
So needless to say when he he
never saw combat but when he
got out he still had that type
of- problem with mental
stability. Because of the
boxing because of his
background there so he has a
lot of trauma to the brain
there- pretty much similar to a
ninety D. when you look at
that. The concussions and all
the things that happened with
boxers he's been very unstable
with his living. He was housed
with a church an Orange County
and they let him live in this
back room for years well. Last
year they sold the church. So
they displace but the pastor
bought him a ban. And he's and
he's obsessed with computers he
always says he owns six
companies in he's doing all
these computer things will
counter intelligence and he's
just. A kick to listen to but a
great man but he- became just
place but these pastor bottom
advance we've been living in
his band we had not seen him
since last June. He walked into
our center. Just the last few
weeks and- it will be
unbearable. How he had not
changed his clothes he had this
huge long beard. But it was
still anyways the happiest man
in the world and he said he
starting all these wonderful
companies again and he's doing
all these things that. Not once
have my veterans ever ever
degraded him and Brough to him.
At any point they offering free
food the offering everything
that they can that's one of our
veterans. Are resource center
offers is we have a
refrigerator with food that we
partner with Orange County.
Rescue mission we Starbucks.
Tax and sandwiches in there so
they would give him sandwiches
more and make sure he could eat
into all. These things. Well
one day I went in there and I
said. What is going on here
does not smell clean in here.
And they said well you know we
have this problem he's coming
in he's not beating and I said
then we got. Take care about.
So I said my new director
maillot and I said. All of the
guys said go to target you buy
anything he needs I want new
clothes and you know I'm sure
sucks whatever he needs to get
it for my in getting. All these
things and get him done well.
Malik took a step further so.
He asked me of any when's the
last time he had baited and- he
said not for awhile. So we took
him to the gym he watched what
clothes he had. And gave them
all these new clothes. And in
the shower. This is kind of a
tear jerker in the shower he
ask Danny. When's the last time
you Bates and he said three
months ago. And he had the
scrubber thing maillot did any
scrap demi said Nancy there was
brown water coming down the
shower and he said it just
broke my heart. So they shave
them and got him all cleaned up
and they brought him back and-
he's there now every Monday to
get a shower with mall any good
to the GM and make sure it is
clean and we washes clothes in
the gym. He still lives in his
van I can't get him house so we
got him social security about a
year ago because he doesn't
qualify or any type of be a
money he is a hundred dollars a
month that's not enough to
really house himself. We've got
to do better than that. This
man deserves better he's the
nicest man in the world but I
can't find in housing I can't
get him anywhere so along those
lines I want you to keep
thinking of Mel but I've got to
ask for you. So my number one
ask is that we do find
transitional housing for
veterans you heard our veterans
up you're speaking about that.
They don't get their funds for
the first few months when they
come to us in the application
they they apply for the
education benefits they have to
wait out its it again you were
Brian state it came to December
he started classes in August.
That's too long to wait and
most of them they don't keep
their finances really well to
where he was lucky. At seven
thousand dollars in the bank
most don't have that. We need
to be able to career test. Our
veterans before they even leave
the base and find out where
they want to go. I had a young
man the other day. That has
been he signed up for all these
computer classes. And he called
me in and actually he was an
attending class. And I called
him and I said so what's going
on because he's teacher sent me
an email and said that. He
Robert in email said he had
suicidal thoughts opinion at
all. So I called them
personally and I said what's
going on I said I need to talk
to you now and I asked him
those important questions in.
And got his information. But he
said to me I don't want to be
in those classes and I said.
What do you want to do and he
said. I I've I've tried to look
into barber school. Will lo and
behold the GI bill will cover
barbers. So he in boulder
barber school we transferred
over is benefits he's now in
those classes becoming a
barber. But we've got a career
test that could have been
easily settled when he came
out. We've also got to have a
lot more. In turn programs-
maybe even to find out what
they want. And increase our
certificated programs. Because
they are coming out and I say
this all the time. With
experience. Plumbing electrical
activity. Diesel mechanics they
need to be able to get into
these union programs get their
certificate of completion maybe
knock off a couple years
because of their experience and
get important. Maybe some are
not going to come to college we
hope they do but they may not
want to but we gotta get amend
ploy that's really vital. And
the last thing that I want
really really focus on and I
think I don't care across the
board we have to treat for
mental health regardless if
they ask for it. When they are
coming out of the military when
they're entering the colleges
every student should go through
a mental health not only
assessment but you know what
we're just going to treat you
anyways we're gonna give you
tools and skills on everyday
life situations that we can get
you through. And I will tell
you right now there's not one
person on this planet that
could not benefit from a
program like that because life
is hard and it doesn't matter
if you're in the military not
you at that on top of it. It
makes it even more difficult so
why not just treat we've got to
take a more holistic approach
on how we help our veterans
that's what we are doing it
Irvine valley ninety we're
making great strides in again
meeting in that date a nerd our
persistence rates have
improved. Immensely we have an
87% persistence rate and 85%
Xin rate are are depressed
rates have decreased immensely
we've started out when I first
started in this five years ago
and testing in getting our
surveys and data collection in.
And I do it through research
department so it's pretty.
Solid we started out in the
high like sixty seven to eighty
percent. In an exciting we're
down 212214% now that makes a
difference because we treat
them regardless if they say it.
And I think that's a by. Our
hope providers coming out and
they sit in there and just help
focus groups and talking Kobe
goals. And the right in the-
center and I. Ask that's what
I'd like you to do and try and
see what you can do. You guys
already made great strides- so
I appreciate an anthem thank
you very much for your time.
Thank you and the news Marshall.
Hi being thank you so much for
calling in your committee to
talk about ending better at
home my name is Marshall I
manage director of the river
county. Development agency- in
the nineteen years that I've
been in county government work
I can tell you that the
highlight in nineteen years was
getting a phone call. In twenty
sixteen from then hud secretary
young Castiel to let us know
that our site county was the
first letter county in the
United States to reach a
functional zero in ending
veteran homelessness so I'm so
thrilled to be able to share
that. Story with you it's been
a few years. We get to relive
it is just a treat for me thank
you. I'm in twenty. In twenty
thirteen was when the riverside
County Board of supervisors-
initiated a an initiative
called valor and what they did
was. Tell all of the department
heads that they wanted to and
we must and the veteran
homelessness. During that time
and as part of valor we
established a sub committee to
address homelessness one to
address unemployment and
another one to address. Poverty
in general. Back in twenty
thirteen the point in time
count for homeless veterans
riverside county showed that
there are two hundred and
eighty five homeless veterans
living in riverside county at
the time. Little did we know.
By a few months later we would
of our the house about a
thousand of. During the five
year period from. Twenty
thirteen to twenty seventeen
apartments community agencies
and the woman the health system
work lab Ridley to build a
coordinated system one that.
Really had of a culture that
prioritize rapid registration
our armed housing of all
homeless veterans. In June of
twenty thirteen we held our
first veteran to boot camp and
that was convene to buy a an
organization called community
solutions I do recall on that
you were there for that-
Mister. It was just such a
pleasure to work with you then
and it is a pleasure to be part
of the thing the that you find
yourself in a few years later.
Now I reflecting back on the
work that we did I think
there's a few factors are
critical to our success one of
them was leadership. The router
initiative was created and
champion by our board of
supervisors that was critical
in getting the community
support and the by and that we-
be required they also directed
all of the county departments
to make ending veteran
homelessness the top priority
of the work that they were
establishing. Number two was
disability the Valar initiative
with highly visible it was a
community campaign which
included the park from. Local
churches and community
residents this week. Number
three we had very strong
community partnerships staff
from multiple agencies work
very closely Allen at on a
daily basis. To house veterans
at that time we were holding
weekly. Calls and we literally
went down the list of every
single veteran that we need in
the pipeline. To find out where
they were in the process so
that there was a an urgency to
the matter on a daily basis.
Number four one we have a
vicious cycle. The bachelor
valor housing team set out and
we didn't think we could do
this to reestablish this goal
set out to house one hundred
veterans in the first one
Hundred Days of the initiative
and at the end of that one
hundred days they quickly and
successfully house the hundred
and forty of them. I can tell
you at the time I in my county
career I was working at the
Housing Authority is. Actor and
I do recall the passion. The
drive and the excitement in the
office a each and every time.
One homeless person was house
there was just a celebration
around the office and it just
made the work. On believable
and it was something I'll never
forget. If we hadn't set that
large bowl in the first place I
don't think we move we would
have moved as quickly. Number
five is housing resources. We
the housing authority at that
time had secured over six
hundred Vash marchers a hundred
and fifty two section eight
project based vouchers and
develop two hundred and seventy
five affordable housing units.
All of which were earmarked for
homeless veterans you really
cannot and homeless. Homeless
veterans. Issues without
housing resources. And then the
last thing I think is a
developing a by name lest we
developed a community wide list
all homeless veterans and
sought to house each and
everyone of them since then
since the inception of that
initiative we've house one
thousand seven hundred and nine
voucher homeless veterans taxes
yesterday morning and I can
tell you that I couldn't be
part of our team. For having
accomplished a great feat.
Thank you. Q. tall for review
and I know that we have a few
questions here so we'll start
with the spelling are you north.
Martel and miss Montgomery
thank you both for being here
both have. Done something
across the state that I think
is recognized as a best
practices as a family member or
Nguyen side it as something
that we hold out as a model for
other communities. And I guess
my question is I'm probably I
think I have for you Mister
Boylan is how can we as a state
do a more effective job at
identifying best practices and
then rolling them out across
the state I think that's nay we
struggle with and just when it
comes to veterans issues but I
think more broadly by. How can
we do better can we take a pro
they're working so well
riverside working so well at.
IBC and roll those out of the
state. Thank you. It's it was
interesting I think early on.
Veterans issue really I mean
obviously we're so I I've I
working or not. Cisco for many
years. There was this period of
this law all I'd say eight
ninety Gulf War was over-
Vietnam veterans are still
primary population of veterans
being served any any supportive
services. Environments goal for
veterans that were seen very is
antiseptic in some ways and in
there aside from the hundreds
of thousands of veterans who it
shop a BA with various
illnesses related their goal
for service that along to be a
side of it is the that part
but- in terms of the community
the homelessness issue that.
All these things really hadn't
come to the- or for it yet-
after the post nine eleven
veterans started coming back in
an educational benefits in in
in and I think the whole system
itself was shocked on non
profits the hippest nonprofits
I mean one to really have their
fingers on the polls really
needed to shift the way they
serve veterans the population
shifted on them almost
overnight. On the needs of
veteran shifted rapidly
everything moved- and the
population of those in need
increased dramatically so at
the time governor brown with
through executive order- put in
place was called the governor's
entering city council on
veterans what this did was said
com one. All from all over the
state anyone who's doing
anything related to veterans-
better specific or not- comes
Sacramento we we're going to
convene and figure. Out who's
doing what where and we're
gonna make sure Reno's charter.
It's quite an undertaking- in
it was. It was a little hard to
get our arms around I was on
the nonprofit side of the world
at that time. On this take
place was really. Really
excited to see. What what it
did was it introduced me to
Nancy and introduced me that
why new Steve from before but
it there just be a lot of
people and everybody started
looking around and knowing. You
know basically when with when
that mapping of sorts was done.
We knew who was doing what
where and to what level and
what they're in in when we
realized we needed to start.
Drilling down into the gap
identify the gaps in then the
service there provided you know
first of all is establishing
the needs than establishing.
The services available and
establishing the gaps. So we
really work through this in a
very systematic way- when I
cannot state was a priority
that- then secretary gravity in
doctor Abbas Yanni when he came
in has just hit the ground
running on this and we really
focused on. Organizing the
state in a way in breaking it
down regionally and identifying
those Lee partners within the
state and making sure they're
connected to the team
originally. And then the all
the service providers within
our cohesive within that
community as well so you have a
community based system of care
state is aware of an educated
to within every communities
throughout the state. And
that's something that we're
very proud of and we've done
very systematically that led
right into what cal top is
which is our own California
transition assistance program.
We identified very early on.
That that was the challenged.
He was center folks off without
a lot of state without a lot of
support they were coming to the
state- and then suddenly find
themselves in need of
something- and Austin and we
where they're at and them not
knowing who to turn to. So
that's where Calvet really tell
tap really sprung from in using
all of those resources and all
those community partners is
starting to develop these
relationships. It allowed us to
understand what funding
challenges there were what
funding was available that was
being used how could we partner.
For funding how can we really
utilize what we Pat. I mean to
see what happened in LA is
outstanding San Diego was kind
of a give me it it's up is
already kind of. Not giving it
was it's a hard work. But you
have a very culturally
competent area you have
everybody who's involved in
knowledgeable about veterans
issues to some because they're
touched in some way. In that
community it's a very military
rich environment LA LA a
completely different type of
place on. So it took a lot more
work in it still takes a lot of
work. But in California rural
areas for the biggest challenge
is trying to develop some
system of caring community
based system of care in rural
areas were very limited. Access
to on any kind services. Are
around. So to answer your
question what that's kind of
process our department went
through to understand in
identified in through this
process like I said. We
identified Nancy how to best
practice of working with Steve.
To get his outside the wire
program on to the community
college campuses group. Prop
sixty three grant that she got
to the Orange County. Well I
have my own prop sixty three
money that our department gets
in in the legislature they
missed. That last year so I had
more to offer. So hearing one
Nancy done I work with Steve.
And department of Veterans and-
in general long who's in
charge. She I guess it you call
the CVS so. Little different LA
the called the military
department of Los Angeles- who
had that up we work with her so
now we have a program. That
we've actually added to it so
we have a mental health
treatment but also now. General
long have staff goes to they
actually do claims as well so
now we have folks going to the
community colleges throughout
LA. Will do claims assistance
and mental health. So it's
those kind of things as we see
them as they go along. We just
work on the fly but now we can
is the state agency be that
nimble. Because we set up the
structure throughout the state
the we understand who all the
players are and what roles they
play. Down to the community
level system of support so.
That's that's the biggest thing
is I mean this. My challenge. I
think being in the nonprofit
world I. Can see this pretty.
Easily the state has a hard
time in in in many different
apart. Getting the money from
the legislature to the street.
I mean that that's that is the
biggest challenge that you can
develop amazing programs but
how do you get that money onto
the street in used effectively-
and I think that something is
department we're very proud of
and I think we've managed to-
figure out ways to do that
quite effectively. Quick
question. What is the what's
the budget for the program that
we have at IBC right now. So
there's no. There are users so
there's no better resource
center in the state has an
actual general fund budget
their college so we my budget
there is probably one of the
biggest budgets because we were
grant so I have a two million
dollar that's an innovation
grant that we can at a utilized
for. Different events about
it's included in mental health-
we're doing a lot of
experimental private type of
thing so we're taking veterans
off campus and we're seeking
how mentally they handle these
things if it if it actually
improves their mental health
status and improve that
isolation factor of being
isolated maybe they have no
support at home or what have
you so we're doing those pre
and post surveys and we're
finding out what's working. On
the other money that we have
coming in I have an Orange
County community foundation
grant I also a minute I'll
service grants from prop sixty
three- and so when he finds
that we have coming in that
makes up my- budget the other
part we have is- assembly woman
Irwin I advocated for with our
our actual on. Going funding so
we are now in the state it. And
I'm going finding and how they
base that is the number of
veterans that you certify per
year so we have to send in a
certification from. From be a
once in Chau what we're doing.
The problem with that is that
colleges with a large amount of
veterans that they certify say
San Diego. They get like a
hundred sixty thousand dollars
my college I certify a smaller
amount even though I care for
eight hundred veterans I don't
certify that me I sort of a
little bit over three hundred.
And then during that time they
give us a time for I only get
forty eight to fifty thousand
dollars so it's not enough to
sustain positions. So for our
budgets are not. Stable across
the state in any better
resource center so. There isn't
any really. Okay and one more
question to a suggestion that
we heard from. Our veterans.
And also for me. With concepts
as- transitional housing with
your- definition and we usually
years. Where you actually have.
A. Housing while you are making
that transition from military
to civilian life for a period
of a month or six weeks
whatever what do you think
about that idea. I as polls I
think it's a great idea I don't
control that money and so I
don't want to spend it for
them. But I can certainly could
I I'll certainly have ideas-
but I think there's that
there's something there that
there's something there there.
Because it's a need it's across
the board in your you know it
it's- the housing crisis is
isn't not. Veteran thing has a
center proportionally
represented but it's students
students better in a non
throughout the state at the
same challenge- so that there's
probably a bigger solution hand
as well but at as a deals with
veterans in the use of the
money. That I think fifteen
million dollars on going is
just incredible I mean there
was a time when there was
actually no support for the
community college so that was
a- that was and I mean. And a
significant. List left to say
the least so that there's
probably some things that can
be done there- and we'd
certainly be be happy part of
that conversation in. In in.
Throw in our two cents in our
ideas for certain. Assembly
member quirk Silva. Again thank
you to all the panelists and I
know that I've met some of you
as I worked in that area a tiny
bit I believe were you doing
the pensions religion Long
Beach a handful of years ago
and I went out with John
Spangler. At that point and I
was very intrigued by the
village this is but six years
ago. I believe. Because it had
many of the attributes that
we're talking about from. A
women in family unit to a
guardian which I've always been
struck by gardens as that's how
I ended up becoming political
twenty years ago at the school
I taught at where we started a
community garden and that was
where. Literally the seeds were
planted- and I'm not being
obnoxious there but but
guardians and people and
wellness there's a huge amount
of research on that. But it was
not only the transitional house
but that it was the permanent
supportive in if you haven't
been out there right- Chen site
tour because- that has always
kind of stayed in the forefront
but one of the things that I do
want to ask about is. Because
the potters. Elige was mention
and I also went out to tour
that. Is that housing not just
for the veterans community but
every community seniors
millennials all of us. Is
becoming out of reach and I
know that we get very. Excited
by new approaches and that was
containers but- Los Angeles and
even here were finding that
some of the affordable housing
models are becoming more and
more- out of reach even if
they're affordable so for
example I've heard in Los
Angeles and I could be wrong
that the four WD could cost
well over six hundred. Thousand
dollars to build but there are
models out there that we've
seen in other places where
there the prefab ideas that
matter talked to a gentleman
who works in Los Angeles he
just went out to Panama last
week to help set up for their
government I thousand units in
its a pre fab where it's all
folds and believe it or not if
you see the model it opens it
up it opens up into a two
bedroom with showers. A small
kitchen the cost to create
that's about twenty three
thousand dollars now of course
you have to have the
infrastructure and all that to
go but- is there any type of
modeling being done and again
this is housing and not only
veterans housing that we could
look at it that could be much
more economical. They can be
built Shasta- any cheaper not
because I want people to live
in cheap homes but because we
want to get the most mileage
out of the dollar we. AB are
there any of those things
you're looking out. Of. Are
there are there is a lot of
experiments out- tiny homes is
one- homes on wheels this is
another- so we're just getting
everything up there that. Cost.
Are you aspects long what are
our partners century housing
and Thomas opera searches are
looking housing at the west LA
via campus. Will be developing
two hundred units of housing.
Over the next five or six years.
Residents struggle district we
have to renovate what is their
of so the that the- less
expensive. Housing options are
not available at that point but
we are also working with
architects who have done a lot
of- experiment là research on
this and they are looking at
modular buildings. These are to
be containers day design a
building such that they can
replicate each apartment. A
single factory and stack them
up and they put a. They they
put a- a front on and it
doesn't look like a much of the
building they're beautiful. So
there's all kinds of things-
being experimented. Is it
getting it's a matter of
getting land. Counties and
cities have a lot of land metro
has of land- so matter of the
city's coming up with that
lapses that. Agencies like ours
on the development agencies can
could put out. And then without
stepping into murky waters here.
And this I also when I was Ana
veterans chair myself in at
that time it will on the
consultant for the Veterans
Committee John Spangler will
also took a delegation out to-
the veterans campus on in Los
Angeles. Is that where they had
built a housing. The hospital
remember the veterans hospital.
The west of the S. western idea
yes yeah and there was a big
issue at that time where they
had built a housing but the
kitchen and all these issues
around the- government the
state working together. But
there was a huge amount of land
there and- then we drove on to
this site it was striking he
not only how much land. But a
lot of the land was being
leased out to other vectors
whether it be a theater. Now
and again the murky water plan
not trying to. Say let's just
all uses but on the trail and
transitional type of housing
and again I know we have
homeless advocates out there.
But they could we do something
as simple as and again not
Holden pizza but even getting
some of our- car dealers to
maybe donate motor homes and if
they say you had a fifty of
those. And that became a
transitional living chest not-
I mean you have to separate but
if you had. Some of the
military the military returning
but not homeless. But they need
to navigate and that you can
have them be on a site like
that for say one month two
months three months and then.
Access other services because I
think get the pyramid sometimes
we do the reverse which is. We
treat something once it's huge
problems over there. As
homeless now of all of these
layers do but if we. For that
same thing in the school
system. But. G. into people
were incarcerated verses the
preventive Chinese after school
programs at the age of it so we
could have a model on land
whether it's veterans lander
other surplus California land
that we could work with the
private sector. To do I mean a
donation of motor homes that
are nice I'm not talking fifty
thousand dollar motor homes but
moderate they could say here's
a place you have all this kind
of a wood stick- hub here. And
there's a time line I. Think
those are some creative
approaches that. Could in the
short term help but in the long
term- keep some of the veterans
getting to the cycle. He like
many because in the end we're
going to have it have some type
of intervention anyhow- for
those that don't put that
intervention were seen them
dying on our streets. So we're
doing things in Los Angeles- as
I said we're developing at that
west of the land. It's a long
term project- we don't break
ground. On the first billing
and all next year. But demi
while. The a is working with
the city and the county to our
create bridge housing on the
line I want to create a hundred
beds a bridge housing using one
of those from instructors-
that's one that there's a new
director up their doctor
Stephen Braverman- and he is
suggesting that the put modular
homes are. On the land. On the
V. a site on the VA site.
There's a there's plenty of
land there okay I'm gonna have
to do is that correct because
if you've been. To it it is up
to the campus is a very large
hand campus right on the-
edges. Of. Is it Westwood. Yes
my press one to one is so you
had this beautiful campus in on
the edges you have that trends
that are dying on the streets
all this grassy rolling hills
on the VA and to me it's a
crime so. Thank you. I'd might
have answered most of my
questions just kind of quickly.
It is sometimes a disconnect
with timing and Alan so- yeah I
think it's kind of intriguing
when you talk about doing
career counseling ahead of time
before they get into the
community college because the
information you're- the
opportunities and community
college by the time. Veterans
here about him off their off in
another direction and
specifically a job with of the
trades we have our carpenters
inventor county are very active
in trying to. Recruit veterans
but- what we're not going
telling community college
students to apply for that
because they are allegedly
going into debt different
direction and yet it might be
exactly the thing that's right
for them so I so- introducing
them earlier to the
opportunities- before they're-
at a community college I think.
An official and maybe that
through cal tap or or being-
you know that's on the- the
bases and then at the same time
I've also heard from veterans.
Hey Nancy veterans that have
come that has. Talk about how
they have this transition
program the military and yet
they're not ready to absorb
most of the information and so
being able to hear all the
second I maybe that's on the
campuses would be beneficial
and so I hope that cal is
looking now after based place
the programs on the bases that
they- move into. Unity colleges
also. We are in and that's the
one of the biggest challenges
because even. Unfortunate that
the governor's military council
the post commanders throughout
the state we have been
incredibly receptive in any
known and I. Hill this used to
be a sore spot for me when I
was in the nonprofit world Sir
if I said the department of. Is
doing what they can and they've
gotten so much better trying to
you know there's some salsa
please post they're they're
doing everything they can it's
hard. To hard deal there folks
leaving going back to all every
nook and cranny country. But
then like I said we try to
identify those books that have
some interest or have no or or
think they may stay in
California. But I think. Even
in what they give us is a
separate day so they have to
week that the gentleman earlier
talked about. Of which is that
DLL. Labor federal funded- kind
of employment crash course
resume writing how to prepare
for interview type stuff with a
very small bit from the for the
federal be a on back. To just
kind of drinking from a fire
hose and- you know it's- the-
cover everything that they-
support of that flies to. Cheat
depending on whether your what
your age is how long you been
and what your- kids all these
different tack so it's just a
lot a- lot of stuff to take in.
What we do is they've they've
afforded us a separate day.
Where we bring universal art is
just our date cal. Day I'm- now
not to bring it. On folks and
they have this opportunity the
best part of the whole day at
the end of everything. Is the
media. Like for your area they
meet then for Orange County
they meet our local interest in
network quirk. Who is the
outrage person for that
community they meet their
actual county veterans service
officer for that community. So
it is forget let's pretend they
don't listen to and hold other
thing and just say you know I
want to pay attention this once
I get out. They will have. The
contact information for the
link who. Links are we require.
Them to know. Everything about
the community and in. Every
entry point in that system to
be connected to that system so
that. That better and
regardless of what entry point
they pick based on their own
personal demographics. We will
be able to communicate with
them. And then also they have
that county veterans service
officer's name phone number.
Contact information. And at
that point the one thing that I
can't get federally from all
that. The twenty five thousand
letters a come back to the
state every year. From the DOD
but what I get through this
process is their personal
email. So we can connect with
them directly which is. Just
everything and that is the
biggest challenge with Pat- and
been able to so yes we do have
that. Connection so. Even if
whatever we don't give them at
that point we can continue to
connect to the but I agree. In
into your point apprenticeships
to so when you work with the
trades the GI bill covers
apprenticeship programs as well
which is an amazing way to use
your GI- and it goes a lot
further in employers love it
and- their statements still is.
In use wall in paid so it's
just a win for everybody. Yeah
and at that it didn't have to
be Nancy. Tell them- used to
qualify you could have
qualified to go directly to you
see. Sense and it could not be
Nancy saying maybe you don't.
To go the- the four year degree
route you really. Love to work
with your hands in the
carpenters have these
apprenticeship programs there
so it's- it's really. It's a
timing issue that that people
the information at. The time
that they- that they most need
at night I. It's a difficult.
It's difficult to get that
correct. But those are the two
issues that I've. Get out
community college they can get
the vets can get all their
information but I have had a
number of people say if
somebody would have just told
me I could have gone straight
to. You see a or cal state at
that that I had the credentials
to do that. We've been trying
to get with the military
commanders as much as we can
and go in and kind of go back
as far as we can before they
get out of it. Is the gentleman
mentioned today that they gave
him this course eight months
prior. The reason behind that
is they're trying to give a
year prior actually. In the
reason behind that is. In
theory. It's call transition
jeep. Goals and- G. P. S.
strategies. So what the
military does not wither tap
program is a year out there's
they're supposed to take an
individual. And identified the
path with. That individual
wants to go down. Whether that.
Cellphone business whether
that's going to school or if
it's going into a trade the
military ideal to their new
track to chat jeep. Transition
GPS program is supposed to
identify those three passed. A
year before they even get out
then that last year in theory
they're supposed to work
towards that passive that's
when they would go through this
process they would figure out
if they're ready for associates
for. Communications the issuer
UC system they would figure out
what trade if they wanted to
put on trade because back to
the career testing that's
ideally when they're supposed
to be doing that. On whether
that's done how it's done it's
not mandatory that part of the
course is not mandatory so we
have very little. Affect on
that process- but through our
relationships with our military
posture in the state we're
trying to at least in
California as much as we can-
reach back. In get involved as
far as we can- is far as dole
le let us. Assembly and just
how many non not. The process
is that were talking about are
not only important for our
military also our young the
Dahle milk multi also. An
example on the rear testing.
Ran a bill through the
Education. Committee exactly on
going back. Sometime in their
senior year preferably their.
Last semester to go through the
career type of processing and
it didn't have to be Acosta
could be going online to one.
And we did not get that through
the education community. A
which you would think like why
would that be it's not because
we see all too often the same
thing is that we have the
students are on track to go to
the four year maybe even
they're going to two year but
they don't know that down the
street in my district.
Particularly with the
apprentice ironworkers program
apama nobody Orange County
knows that but it's a four year
apprentice program many of the-
those that complete that
program are making well over
twenty five dollars an hour
working on. At Disneyland at
the Star Wars build buildings
are where is basically- we have
the carpenters union and one of
park- four year apprentice
program and so just even
working with the high schools
let alone our military to try
to get that information you
would think that. Shouldn't be
as complicated but believe me I
almost feel like- just making
the flyer to show on the
pathways these are all the-
type of professions that are
right here within your county
and I think we've talked about
that before so maybe to between
this hearing. At us up here and
all the good ideas we can come
out with that type of. The you
know like these are right here
if you don't have to pay eighty
thousand dollars for a
certificate when you can get
paid to be an apprentice. And
that not only good for a vet.
But it's good for our young
adults. Thank you so much thank
you and I up on this last I
just have to did you have the
one comment I wanted to say on
that that. Is in line with what
cancers the state chances are
guide guided. Pathways and
you're supposed to be doing
that. The guiding them. What
type of assessment that
completed and where they're
going there. And one last thing
I did want to comment you
brought up the topic that. She
forgot to mention. Mention
seniors. A lot of our veterans
are coming back and finding
temporary housing by renting a
room in seniors homes. And that
is something that is viable in
we should start looking at too
because it helps. Fifty pulled
on that one. They can do
repairs around the house the
senior feel safe. They can they
the room it helps them
financially. And I have one
senior woman in Irvine area
she's rents to three veterans
it charges them six hundred
dollars a month. That helps her
because she lives on a very
small amount of money per month
their social security is
extremely small. And she has no
income but she owns the house
and she does one lose it. So
that's another Avenue that we
can actually look at that the
Bible throughout the state
because we have such a large
senior population coming on-
we're gonna be 40% seniors
pretty soon here everybody's
going over sixty. But we can
actually offer that type of
housing by betting those
individuals out. Making sure
that there is some type of
education prior to going into
that housing for the for the
veteran student and for the
senior that is doing that. And
I believe we could start
excellent program by doing that
too so that's another great
thought we should think up. And
you are all out of the box
always. I okay I do real quick
questions because we do have
one more panel- for miss
Marshall. You house I think he
said close to fifteen hundred
vets what type of housing that
they go to did they go to
grandma's house or did they- go
to the HHT. A developments.
Where did you send them all and
how's the mall they pretty much
all of them use start ash not
yours and they use them to
rent- privately owned
apartments and single family
homes. That was the majority of
them yes. All right and then
I'm not sure who can answer
this in a really quickly to-
but is there room for
improvement of VH eighty. Are
always. Of I'd have to get it
again. A little while. Change
that we have requested and I
think there's regulations X.
that is to get some of that
money we now the VGH P. money-
is- replenishes a bridge loan
that we get we pay interest on
that bridge loan so save us
several hundred thousand
dollars if we can get that of
the change be money up front
rather than it taking out the
appraisal that we get okay what
we may perhaps we can talk
about the rest the changes
after. Thank you very much this
was a accident panel. Thank you
so much for joining us and
we'll go ahead and call of our
panelists for panel three I
would like to welcome. Backs he
had who is with a aye Orange
County ninety a- dilemma Wendy
from at the Orange County
Housing homeless services
department. And George Sir see
who's here from jamboree
housing corporation
. Thanks for
being here now text you have a
presentation that you're going
to walk there. What we need to
do to get that happened. We'll
go ahead and start with you.
Thank you
. Good afternoon it is
a pleasure and a privilege to
be able to be here and to talk
about the work that United Way
has got currently under way on
our plans for- scaling this up
pretty dramatically over the
coming months and over the next
year. As we already. Number of
community the cross country
have been able to reach
personal zero for veterans.
Check. Now three state in
seventy a communities and as we
heard earlier riverside is the
only community and California
in able to reach functions zero
data. Quirk to hop I wanted to
talk and share about our
welcome home O. C. program-
which is the program that we
were fortunate enough to
receive funding from the state
budget and so I'm going to give
you a roof over but the from
talk. Specifically about our
work the bat population. Home
see based feedback. On the
three how are three four
happened a thirties he. But the
difference is that people had
when they were. What's this
about the actual fine on board
that would be willing to and-
that so we are back from
participation Orange County the
corner apartment thirty ation
from members. Housing
authorities designed a ramp to
help were caught. In the middle.
But we make sure we keep those
opened. We actually cover cost
of application fee double your
house. Building fees and bacon
payment a lot does lose any
ripping you off for the unit
you are not Burke- then we also
guarantee that will be
appropriate levels support
services provide page every.
I'm sure there have been can be
stabilized. We have some
additional benefits to that- so
we have our staff on hand to
address any issues that may
occur also dated damage rent
cation. But some may a rock.
One would not her caught out of
pocket- are there any sure
maybe he also a record Xin you
are. Owners because of the of
an in home. Insure that the rep
and provide both based
furniture. Per unit to be home.
The hot. Make sure that those
items out of storage and in
turn you on. Since we launched
our our program or initiative-
we did a small pilot for a
number of months and we scaled
up in March this year and we
have to date eighty three
people from fifty four
household. Yeah I would use a
lot about you from the Orange
County and the- RT the date.
With that five. We're tired
housing restructure me jurors
and first from the county
Housing Authority we also have
thirty four owners in our
network so have thirty four
property owners who offer us
units to be able to be used for
this program at the moment we
have an average of five point
seven leases being signed a
months almost six households.
Every month that are moving in
with their vouchers. Your
program it's kind of this
unique combination of bringing
many different clip to the will
to ensure that we can. Who have
of your in hand be able to get
up street and almost as quickly
as possible. So the Cooper
bring many players together to
enter the over hurdles. Thanks
for make sure that homeless. We
as possible we began our
veteran pilot program earlier
in the summer and to date we
have had thirteen. To be able
to help include chilled. And
this is in our account housing.
Our roles hi là came to be a.
The responsible for finding
property owners securing unit.
Work through any people that
the housing expertise hired.
Please units and system.
Veterans responsible for
complete. The better. The
responsible provide a case
manager hello veterans view
your partner. Appointments to
ensure that turned fully. In
our next stage of welcome home
O. C. as we are scaling up our
veterans initiative we will be
able to work all hard ouch is
that a- issued here and Orange
County. Chip Anna. I am not a
high housing already are
already in our. Connected
veteran. County oranges March.
Bill Broyles county orange cord
blood and pieces from there I
am. It will be so on track with
nonprofit service for the part.
With the fall. Of our- ending.
Veteran. Going for the present
case com but the. The service
provider part is will there be
ensuring that our partner
welcome home OC program
requirements currently I wanted
to let you know that are least
separate from when we receive
an application packet until a
veteran is housed. Is thirty
five point eight days until
they move in. And we currently
have nine veterans that we're
working with right now to place
into housing. Our next steps
for us the United Way hiring
dish stop for awhile. So we can
skate the only. That number
caption needs sure get many
trans post with the. Possible
also at work the sub
contracting process process.
There's no simple Sir this is
crucial sure. And how. We're
all or work with. Just one
process for referrals welcome
hosted. Pretty up for awhile
network met met or property in
our county. Rents and are you
requesting that they can assist
with this endeavor. I will
calls there- and there are just
a couple of things as I was
listening to comments earlier
that I wanted to be sure to
address and to just kind of
bring up to the forefront- one
of the focus areas for
questions was just around any
challenges that there may be.
So I just wanted to share a
couple of the challenges that
we- think we may be facing or
are currently facing one is
around veterans with zero
income and when that comes to
housing sustainability and the
collective work a case managers
and the VA to ensure that
veterans are getting access to
any benefits- income is crucial
for housing stability. As this
is an area of our system that
it would be great to have some
more attention on. Another area
of challenge- that we seem may
come in the future is when rent
increases. Are higher than what
the voucher will allow for
payment. And so we are looking
at potentially once those
twelve month leases- are kind
of through- through the first
year and we're looking at
potential rent increase. We are
anxious to make sure or to look
at how there might be possible
ways to supplement. Perhaps the
state might be able to provide
some additional funding to
supplement that balance. That
we're not constantly having to
mayor veterans from one unit to
another to meet those rent
requirements. Another challenge
that we are concerned about is
what happens when somebody is
placed into scattered site
housing. Whose acuity level is
actually too high for the
scattered site model who needs
to be at a project based
permanent supportive housing
units. So this is something
that we are concerned about- it
will require coordination
between the VA the housing
authorities the county the
continuum of care and permanent
supportive housing providers-
and just something that we want
to be mindful of where we can
collaborate together to ensure
that veterans receive the level
of care. That is appropriate to
their needs to keep them
stabilized. And another fought
just to throw out here- around
national best practices so many
of those communities that have
successfully addressed
homelessness did so because
they adopted. The mers
challenge instances where mers
declare that they are dedicated
to ending veterans homelessness
and it's a way to bring
publicity to the goal and the
calls of ending veterans
homelessness and it becomes a
rally cry for the community-
this is also a great way to
brief. Mares locally about what
is happening around the issue
of Veterans homelessness and so
just wanted to bring that. Xin
in your consideration. Thank
you. Well thank you and thank
you for all the as the work in
your vision and leadership on
this issue I really do think
it's such a smart strategy it's
really exciting to get an
update on. The way that you're
getting early traction here I
think what we'll do is we'll
and we'll hear from our other
panelists and then add to
questions with the group so- ms
Lundy. Thank you for joining us
again. Hi good morning thank
you for having me again. I
think back to the phenomenal
job at highlighting the work
that has been going in our
community about some veteran-
efforts and quickly housing
veterans- I'll provide a little
bit of the background context
on. What led to all of this
great momentum and work that is
being done. At thirty in the
summer in November and December
of two thousand eighteen. Of
the county started having
conversations the nonprofit and
volunteers of America and the
VA locally. And to transition
the veteran registry. And to
the county for oversight. I'm
we found that this was a in
line with our- larger role as
the leader of the pre made
entry system and the lead- for
the continuum of care. I'm just
kind of being able to be a
competing body for all the
different veteran and nonprofit
providers to focus. On veteran
specifically. I'm step from
there we have the January point
intend cam at a loss to. I'm we
can file the veteran registry
and really have a good grasp of
what that number look within
our community- and- ever since
then- when we released the
point in time town. At there
was the director from the board
of supervisors to come up with
a strategy to and veteran
homelessness. And not let to
marching home to and better
homes Orange County. What we
did is we can be in a body of
Veterans stakeholders thing he
leaders in our community-
nonprofit service providers
United Way veterans service
providers and although that
engage with veterans. And to
come up with a strategy that
over. That open a dress some of
the barriers to helping. Them
immediate actions that we could
do to connect veterans to
restart the- heart right and if
I am and we also think goals
and reducing. The length of
time it takes for veterans to
find healthy. At the- exact
back share with you about being
able to least up and thirty
five days that's the main thing
and even some. That we have.
Greater success stories low we
have health. Peak of better
with the same day. At. Early
work. I would be very strategic
in chipping away at the number
and making sure that. The
structure that we built in help
veterans and their
homelessness. This is the level
and will be able to be re
created for new veterans that
and her homelessness. Along
with the marching home strategy
and the veteran the board of
supervisors also. Providing
additional dollars to help with
healthy navigation I am well
there are some programs that
provide housing like welcome
home most seeing their still
that component of navigating
the veteran to the VA
appointment to complete their
application. To than help them
with the viewing and all the
steps in between that with the
gap in our community after the
board of supervisors under the
contract for in and- Asian and
the awful supporting some of
those veterans that have zero
income and to help them connect
to the V. F. so office and make
sure that they're able to-
veteran benefits. And also
finding creative ways to pay
for rack has some veterans are
able to manage to pay their
portion of the rent or managed
to pay their utility even when
the half zero in half of the we
wanted. To provide additional
avenues for those veterans and
not. Additional files or
barriers to their housing. I
have. The we continue to manage
veteran registering and we're
starting to do focused events.
And to make sure that we
connect the veterans in our
veteran registry to vouchers.
So yesterday an honor veterans
day. We created a connection
event where we are going to the
veterans on a registry and
bottom into the Housing
Authority office. We have the
VA we had on the hand housing
authorities that man a housing
authority. United Way with the
welcome home and a couple other
partners. So that people could
connect to a one stop shop.
Complete your have Mashable
Haitian complete your intake
your briefing packet for the
hard facts about her with the
helping authority. And then
connect to one of the service
providers to do some additional
healthy navigation the support
yeah or complete the
application for a welcome home.
And does really. Making sure
that veterans are able to
access the resources as easily
as possible I'm- so from
yesterday's event alone we had
ten veterans of the voucher.
These were ten veterans that
had been on the registry the
longest and high. Very complex
situations. That need a lot of
you know. Working three up I'm
and then at the mention
previously we have I'm five
veterans that were house. I
would say the strategy and plan
to end veteran homelessness is
really going to require all of
our collective effort. In all
of our collective Ashford. Is
already making progress right
would have 15% decrease and
veteran homeless lessons we
have that started to arrange
herself to be a lot more
intentional in our delivery of
services and coordinating those
services at. And we are very
lucky to have a lot of the key
partners at the table with- the
housing authority the veterans
service office. The health care
agency with their- see for vets
program that really target the
needs of the veterans on the VA
has been. Very helpful in
making themselves available and
events locally we don't have a
hospitals a lot of that kind
that the veterans have to
travel to Long Beach. And to be
able to get their services. But
they are acceptable for us in a
way that. Is really hurting
reducing the barriers- and then
we're offering very I'm happy
to have a couple partners that
are helping us with the
employment component. I am of
helping veterans it's reached
first ability including good
well- and Bonta America US.
Bats were off the partner table.
And I would also note. That.
The Santa Ana veteran village
in the placenta veterans
village with George will speak
about- in more detail are gonna
be opening in twenty twenty and
this will provide an additional
hundred and twenty five units-
it creates a community for
these veterans to be able to
succeed and be able to have the
support that they need I'm it
also creates an opportunity for
those very for those that are
that have been unable to search
for her to look at helping. In
the private market. And so it
creates. An Avenue for them to
be house I'm if they have been
searching and they haven't been
able to overcome those barriers.
I would also note am. Now
there's other I'm going
progress and building
additional affordable housing
in permanent supportive housing
through the Orange County
finance trust with the goal of
building those twenty seven
hundred units. As we look at
the resources that we have
available and we do look at all
the resources are available and
by extension the scattered five
model verses the- village model
is something that will take
into consideration to make sure
that we match the back to the
most appropriate resource. And
when it's available or trying
to support them in their
transition. To whatever works
for them past. We are very
excited to continue our work in
and then veteran homelessness
we feel that we have the
adequate resources- in terms of
vast vouchers at this point we
have more vouchers than
veterans. But that's not to say
that more veterans- cannot use
them the VA has also been
working with us aye reducing
the criteria for how to bash
words sometimes very stringent
to mean. I'm chronic
homelessness they have opened
it to all homelessness. Level
for that is a huge. Resource
for our community to make sure
that we are able to connect
more people to the- after some
not like them when you. Well I
think one thing that's that's
been really exciting for me to
see just says. I'm here this is
such a powerful partnership
between. Our local government
and the private sector in our
non profits coming together to
solve this issue so it's
really- it's exciting. On with
that of two here. Mister Circe
from you thank you. Well to be
here assembly woman
Petrie-Norris and when thank
you very much for the
invitation and to. The joint
oversight committee- I is
George Sears in the chief
operating officer jamboree. My
responsibilities encompassed
designing and delivering
supportive services at all of
our- affordable housing
developments is a nonprofit
organization. Our fundamental
responsibility to ensure that
our communities are sustainable
and delivering best practice
services across our entire
portfolio- said and the better
your which will be our first-
homeless veterans project. And
so we're very excited although
it's not our first permits
sport of housing projects so
we're- applying the lessons we
have learned and also I'll talk
a little bit about how we're
partnering with- veteran
services. Organizations and in
terms of designing our service
delivery for almost that's an
Orange County. Were very
pleased to be here today- end I
should mention in already six
communities where we do our
annual surveys of our
residents. We know that we're
serving between eight hundred
and one thousand. Veterans in
our affordable housing
communities. As well already so
I think that's a an invisible
part of the veterans programs
that people take advantage of.
And I just to make a point
about- what is needed to end
homelessness in general which
includes I would say veterans
hopelessness is a subset of
that. Although has a different-
supportive services dimension
to it. It is fundamentally
built on the same principle
that I we have a housing
shortage crisis. And so.
Housing. Action in the creation
of new units is essential serve
the entire problem. And to meet
the challenge and so we are
very grateful to be- really
selected by the city of Santa
Ana- help with funding from the
county of orange- to- to
deliver these units so. Santa
Ana veterans village with the
largest homeless veterans
single purpose housing project
in Orange County- mercy housing
in Placentia has the Placentia
veterans village under
development. We will complete
that project and began lease up
in on February first of next
year so we're we're coming
right up on it and we're very
excited about that opportunity.
In addition in Orange County we
have another one hundred and
nine. Veteran housing units
scattered throughout a variety
of housing opportunities in
Orange County so- that's a
hundred and eighty four units
of our own including the- the
fifty from Placentia veterans
allege and mercy housing-
there's a good number of
housing units coming on to
target. What we have identified
in the point in time can all
echoed the flexibility that the
VA is providing in terms of
being flexible on the exact
definition of homeless- that's
that are able to be served by
bash vouchers I think that's
that's a central. Another.
Invisible population that we
see not being attended to and a
growing challenge- which you
may have heard of is the-
errands who are homeless. And
have a less than honorable
discharge that challenge of
serving that population in I
think for the best that were
here earlier the very
eloquently documented the
challenges of. That you face
coming out of combat work
service did you Asians- being
that. Process out of military
service with a less than
honorable discharge and then
not being able to be service
can at all with the VA creates
enormous challenges in terms of
being able to use- high housing
benefits. Are targeted at
better it so I think that's an
invisible population. We are
aware of and we're struggling I
think going to struggle to
address in the future so
hopefully that will become a
priority. In terms of a senator
veterans village. Which is only
the first seventy five units of
another hundred nine as I
mentioned that we will be
bringing online in the next two
years- what we have learned is
that what we don't know we can
be taught by people who have
experience so steep pack is of
course one of the renowned
experts in maybe in the
country. On on housing homeless
vets am providing supportive
services and so where we
learned a lot from Steve- one
of his ex colleagues on our
team the jamboree advising us
on how we design these program.
We're hiring bats with bringing
and- the good will tear any
center veterans legal institute
strength and support which
provides- veterans. Psychiatric
services and psychological
services. In two of our
communities so it's senator
better is village which I. Hope
will get invitations to your
and that you'll be able to
attend the grand opening and in
the spring. But one of the
essential features that we
realize is that these
communities do become centers
of service delivery to the
veterans community in the
surrounding neighborhood. So
the state federal local
governments are investing
millions of dollars in the
creation of these physical
platforms. And what we know is
that there are veterans need
the same services that many of
almost Besser seeking. Who live
in these communities so what we
did at Santana is we designed
five thousand square feet a
community services space we're
good will Terni center. The L.
Y. strength and support the VA
case management team can all
have an office. And a public
service footprint there so that
they face outward along First
Street near harbor Boulevard in
Santa Ana- there is the
opportunity for people to come
in and- who need to access
services from these. Highly
valuable organizations right
there in the Santa Ana
community as opposed to having
to travel to another
neighborhood another community.
So there's a walk in
opportunity that we find
extremely valuable and also
makes it possible for these
great service for others to
partner with us. By having a
physical presence in these
housing developments so it
makes it a service rich
environment not only for the
residents who live there. But
office also for the surrounding
community so we're really
pleased with our partnerships
and- and hope to- replicate
that in our. Next single
purpose debtors housing
development. I without I'll
conclude my remarks and just
say that- we're very proud to
be an Orange County founded
based organization that has a
nonprofit corporation who seeks
to develop additional housing
for all sorts of vulnerable
populations were honored to be
able to begin to participate in
this and our partnership with
the county and the city of
Santa Ana in particular is. We
feel very grateful and honored
and a great deal of
responsibility to- to do the
right thing by our debts who
have come home deserve to be
careful. Thank you. Thank you.
To add as that is banks
mentioned there are there when
the challenges with the
scattered site model is that
there are that's where the ag
cuties too great for that model
to work are the services that
are twenty provided that
entrants villages. Going to be
able to serve the needs of that
population. Yes we're we're
finding I appreciate. Deputy
secretary boilers comments
about the PhD program the
demand- to insure you know
using that one mechanism which
we're not having to use mercy
housing using a Placentia but
the standard that was embedded
in the policy language about
having a high capacity services
plan embedded within the
development strategy and the
application is essential so yes
we have clinicians- we find
about two hundred thousand
dollars out of our operating
budget to provide support
services- with train staff. As
well as the manage the
collaborative that deliver all
the services so we'd be a lot.
We are both directly delivering.
To the deaths through our own
staff as well as collaborating
with the VA and other
organizations to serve the most
high acuity debts that you can
find on the streets- we're
we're anticipating that we are
taking of the people who are
most challenging to serve in
our work in what are the
funding streams that were able
to tap into. For the for the
service side. Well what we did
was we identified what we
thought was a necessary
standard based on at vice and
experiences that both we've had
an all of our advisors AT so we
essentially bill the budget-
before we went looking for-
underwriting for the entire
project. So we kept designing
the underwriting strategy over
and over again until we were
able to find the operations of
the property and we treated the
services- funds as simply a
part of the operating costs so
what did that mean we had to do
probably about another two to
three million dollars worth of
capital had to be acquired. So
that they could we could under
right. Not quite a quarter
million dollars of funds for
support of services every year
right into the operating budget
so that included- bonds that
eight state bonds that included
9% tax credits. That included-
pro project based vouchers the
bash vouchers from the city of
Savannah- which with which we
were able to secure additional
data. So that we could find
those services so it was
usually using our traditional
again we didn't go after the H.
H. B. which would have been
another option. But we were
able to fund those supportive
services using the traditional
mechanisms that affordable
housing projects across the
state have used for years- it's
just that we took us special
care to. Outline the
requirement for the funds up
front. I just have one more
question about- Epona hi to the
full panel which is. So as you
have been through this journey
now are there opportunities
where. I as as a local assembly
member are the roadblocks nay.
That we can help clear are you
know ways that we can make it
easier. To do the work you're
doing an easier for us to get
veterans the services that they
need. Number. That is the
fantastic question and thank
you as always for your passion
for- working to address at
veterans homeless. I think
looking at that kind of what I
referenced earlier around rent
increases- and as were being
coming towards the end of those
initial twelve month leases for
people who can house. I think
that is an area that we could
look into further together. My
initial thought and then- one
of the areas that we're looking
at as well as is the ongoing
funding stream for support
services. And so- as George
mentioned they've been able to
build it into their funding
strategy for building I'm
project based housing but for
this guy right side and to be
able to provide additional
support services to what the VA
can offer- the funding for
that- were incredibly grateful
for the funding that we
receive. We know that there
will be at a time frame for
that will and- and so
potentially in our help for
ongoing funding streams. For
their support services in the
scattered site model. Thank you.
I would say the opportunity to
look at that veterans that
towards managed the ones that
are other than honorable just
in making sure that there is
some level of service to
resources for them is outside
the traditional model from the
VA and we are seeing that being
an increase in our community
I'm and locally we're fortunate
that we have to and- continuum
of care dollars that targets a
specific project for that
community but I don't think
it's going to be enough. I am
at the population grows. I
would also just add that- I
think there are hidden pockets
of. Senior veterans which I
believe steep back addressing
his comments- what we're
finding of those. You know I'm
roughly. With Chris last
surveyed last year's side I'm
saying eight hundred one
thousand seniors. I'm sorry
that is a good section of those
are seniors and a good number
of those are living a month to
month- because of their
inability to manage their own
care and services and- finances
and so we find ourselves at
those properties I don't have
any. Veterans services but
print at all using our case
management team to try to help
those that's of find their soup
long term sustainable housing
options even though they may be
living in. A unit that- they
were eligible for fifteen years
ago that was fifty or 60%
average median income unit.
We're seeing a growing
population of senior veterans
who are not sustainable in the
current living situation. Well
thank you all again for joining
us today really appreciate your
perspective on all of your work
leadership on this issue. Armed
with that will go ahead and
this panel and I will open it
up for public comment there's-
anyone who would like to make a
statement. Yes. I'm Jeff
storeroom retired colonel in
the United States Army and have
face these issues. Going to tap.
With a everyone else plus
happen to deal with some other
things related to transition
out. The comments today and
please correct me if I'm wrong
but I. This is a systemic wide
problem it seems like it's not
only dealing with armed
California issues- but also at
the federal level. And also
with the department of defense
and the military. It seems to
me the re the weekly today was
our consultation or liaison
with the department of defense
not. A senior- but with our
local you scraps in. All those
liaisons and me. But if we
don't are. My sense is it not
commanders perhaps don't know
about a lot of things that we
have discussed today terms of
all the problems are being.
Despite our doubts when they
get out. So I went out of the
service com PTSD- and- I also
out of the service in a state
of. Shock being in the service
for thirty years going back to
the suit in world. And in just
like wow what what is office.
He now is very different
culture of very different unity.
About this is not only do we
seems like would really doing
some really cool things here
once got that. And then
transitional state in town.
Someone before that seems to me
like if we're not doing this we
need to get together
commanders. To tell about the
state of affairs of what had.
Happened into their military
that's when they leave. And how
is it that they can better
assess there are military
members water still in the
service getting out. Not just
tap program but maybe at the
end of July but level. And I
was thinking that- it may not
in terms of our area maybe
something might be it National
Guard or reserves. Our local
communities and perhaps a Los
Alameda this might be a good
place. To think about doing
something like this I just
thought about this today as we
were talking I don't have a
concept for you of operations
about how to do it. But I think
this is a weak blank. And just
a- brief story when I was
leaving. Bar tab. The dial the-
often decided at the last
minute. To pay. Me up bus. Are
normally you're paid in the
military or two weeks they
decided we're not going to pay
your mid March. So you're gonna
have to get out and then you
will get your- another month or
so. Our I was livid. And so
when I got when I got out I
went home I wrote an email to
fenced financial accounting
agency. Yeah when this is
what's going on- and I didn't
quite to in this manner the
weather in forty five minutes
of surprise the call from the
CEO bass wondering what. I'm in
my Ste and so I told them what
was going on and she said we
will handle this. And then the
five minutes I got a call from
my own posts and they said we
are going to take care of this
problem and we are going. To
give me math Hey to all these
people who are get out. One is
going to happen in the military
is was senior ship there for
our senior leadership gets
upset enough and create. Climb
in in a situation immediate
action so what else that may be
helpful to understand about the
military. Miss Parker
bureaucracy but when. Senior
leaders decide to take action.
I guess colonels or so. Thanks
very quickly which means also
they can make impediments. To
rock things taking place like
tap. Now in terms of out to
help it's called on the rise
strength of the unit and then
science. And often times the
size of this very well so
people who must be going to
tapped on Kobe as any to do
other things with the unit. And
so these math the things that
management to be more aware of
two. So anyway are. Very much
well. Thank you for your
service and thank you also for
being part of our seventy
fourth assembly district
veterans Advisory Council. Good
afternoon my name is Khan the
city of Costa mesa. Mayor Foley
are was- present that she had
another and that she had to
attend she asked me to make
some notes on her behalf today.
Firstly she's extremely
grateful to these only members
for holding this hearing here
in the city of Costa mesa and
for the special attention being
paid to this concern. Since
twenty four Costa mesa's
network for homeless shins
assisted one hundred and
seventy two almost turns in the
city. In April of this year the
city almost assisted. Twelve
turns and house two of them. So
far Costa mesa Sir is being
funded from existing source.
All fund so additional funding
for six the step up to for to
provide these services directly
great prove their ability to
serve our state. Mayor Philip
also wanted to share a little
personal insight based on her
brother's experience who
recently medically retired
twenty three years serving in
the United States are.
Merrilees call to action
include first allow cities who
are serving homeless and direct
access to funds that having
through an agency. Second close
the gap for veterans receive a
letter health insurance but you
cannot have prescriptions
filled if they're not the
debate or the VA. For example
her brother was recently
visiting. Desperately needed
his medication he was able to
fulfill the prescription from
the are at the or at the local
yes because it would cost him
six hundred dollars when he
normally would have paid thirty
dollars six. Thirty continue to
inventory all appropriate state
county and federal. Expedite
the building a veteran work for
housing because it is law legal
and values that prevent us from
hopping hopping affordable
rates. Like the veterans who
spoke today heard many stories
of veterans in the community
spending nearly fifty percent.
Their income on renting a
smaller more. That is
unsustainable. Thank you again
for your. You for bringing this
hearing Sacramento in into the
city of Khost the- mayor fully
looks for working with our
assembly representative.
Between and each of you.
Collaboratively in any way she
can thank you again. To make a
payment. Thank you again to all
of our panelists for joining us
today and for your leadership
and focus on this issue I think
my two big takeaways number one
I think there's a lot as our
incredible progress being made
here in Orange County to
address the crisis of veteran
homelessness and to achieve the
goal of any veteran
homelessness in twenty twenty
and I think my other. Major
take away is that clearly a lot
has to go wrong and there's
gonna be a lot of cracks that
someone slips through in order
for veteran to wind up homeless
and it does feel like so often
we do not take action until
it's a crisis and so I would
love to. Be part of a continued
recession on how can we do our
job before it for people- speed
through the cracks how can we
invest more in prevention and
more in early stage
intervention. So with that
thank you all for joining us
and we are to